[Music]
it's Thursday June 9th 7th not 9th that
was me poking my head out of the butt of
a giant cow and that's all that I'm
going to say about that light sound and
position check for the Weather Channel I
know what you're thinking where did he
get that amazing yellow light in the
background just to come back for us in
light bulb with some tissue paper
wrapped around it I'm so clever
thought maybe you and the nerdfighters
would appreciate an increase in
production value which means no clutter
behind me maybe a little bit more light
on my face dark no patterned shirt no
they might be giants posters regular
kind of frame head and shoulders sort of
this business or like this business
sideways face shots okay this actually
isn't for you in the nerd fighters this
is for the Weather Channel because I'm
going to try and get my ass on the
station and I don't know that that's
gonna happen and it's a little bit sad
they're being finicky about me living in
the middle of nowhere if I lived in LA
or something they wouldn't have any
problems at all getting me on the
station since I live in Montana they
called it a daunting task I don't want
to be a daunting task I just want to be
on the Weather Channel hey green clean
technology expert hey green
editor-in-chief eco geek gorg Hank green
satisfied cat owner Hank green your
baby's daddy Hank green addicted to my
pants which brings me to my pants one
evening I left my pants and then the
next morning when I went back to my
pants there were over 300 registered
users in my pants that had posted like a
thousand posts in my pants at first I
was worried my pants had gotten too big
for its britches but then I realized
that I was just never going to be able
to conceptualize and participate in all
of my pants I'm sorry about that but my
pants have gotten very big
quickly whoo nerve fighters geez you
guys that's some impressive forming well
done I am so glad that I created that
forum you guys are amazing discussion
surrounding the evil baby orphanage and
the presidential election
I am never again going to lack for book
suggestions woohoo
it's very exciting thank you for your
support I think it's really weird that I
sometimes get paid in gift cards like
why do I need a hundred dollar gift card
to CDW can't you give me a hundred
dollars so that I can pay rent I think
that maybe The Weather Channel calling
hello hello Sid Moore from The Weather
Channel I also wanted to ask like what
would the byline I don't know what the
word is this don't put comm because that
would be a disaster cuz it's dot-org
yeah it's okay it's so long and painful
story cool thanks a lot yeah awesome bye
oh I'm gonna be other weather channel oh
my god that is the dirtiest thing in the
world to be excited about Wow
I would do my happy dance but this setup
is fragile I should show you this is my
tripod it's some books on a stool and my
MacBook is in my lap and that's how I'm
controlling everything from my command
station here if I did a happy dance it
would all fall over this is me like
touching that's why I'm not doing a
happy dance but I would otherwise well
I'm running out of time and space on my
hard drive so I have to clean that out
before the Weather Channel calls
tomorrow and I will see you tomorrow